shifted gears to kind of focus on some
optimism here at a tough time for the
industry focusing on not just you know
the trouble and the pricing here but as
prices go down jobs start to dry up so
you launched a new company here that
really focuses on those jobs and i'm
curious as to how many you're actually
seeing
yeah thanks for having me um if you
think of the job market you know one of
the biggest problems in the world right
now is that the global debt to gdp and
also in the us debt to gdp uh is
skyrocketing and everyone always focuses
on the debt side of the equation hey how
can we stop taking on more debt but
there's another side of the equation
which is how do we grow gdp faster and
obviously job creation is a key piece to
that and so our idea 18 months ago was
basically just how do we get the best
people in the world working on the
fastest economic uh sector uh from a
speed and growth standpoint and that
tends to be the bitcoin and crypto
industry now of course as market prices
go down bitcoin's drawn down 70
uh since about november of last year uh
there are plenty of companies that are
doing hiring freezes or layoffs but
there's still tons and tons of companies
that
are hiring and so just in the last 18
months we've helped over a thousand
people get a job in the industry uh and
we've been doing a lot of kind of
corporate training uh both for crypto
native firms but also non-crypto native
firms uh as well and i think what you're
seeing is uh there is some short-term
pressure because of price but over the
long term most people in the industry
both the entrepreneurs and uh the
incumbent companies they're very
long-term bullish and they continue to
invest in the space but pump 18 months
that included what was still a bull
market in crypto and now we're in a very
very different environment so to what
extent are those jobs really drying up
and are the jobs that are out there
changing to enter a new environment it's
a great question um if you think about
that thousand uh people that we've
helped get a job 400 of them or so was
last year uh so in some way actually
we've seen it pick up uh and what you're
seeing is uh there's a lot of venture
capital that's being invested in the
space there's a lot of companies that
now are hitting uh kind of scaling uh
they were started over the last two
years now they've kind of found product
market fit and they begin to actually
hire and kind of step on the gas and the
other thing you have to remember as well
is that there's just so many companies
that are getting started there's almost
a kind of overwhelming of the market and
really i think one of the most
interesting parts of this story is not
just the the pure aggregate job creation
uh but also it's a brain drain from
silicon valley and wall street you know
almost on a daily basis uh myself or
someone on our team will talk to very
high level uh folks at large
corporations at large financial
organizations uh and they say look you
know now's the time they've been
thinking about it for a while they're
ready to make the jump and they want
help navigating uh finding a job
somewhere in the bitcoin crypto industry
and so i don't think that necessarily
job creation's slowing down uh i think
it's just kind of shifting between
different types of companies you know
nfts were really really hot in q3 last
year uh maybe not so much now you just
saw open c layoff 20 of their staff as
an example and so there are some
sub-sectors where there's transitioning
but uh still the job growth is pretty
incredible and still accelerating i'm
curious about your own investors how did
you go through the process of raising
money for inflection points why is peter
thiel interested in the future here of
more jobs in crypto and uh is he
invested anywhere else that you know of
to promote the industry
yeah you know look the mission of our
company we started 18 months ago and it
wasn't really ever an idea of hey let's
go raise money and do any of this we
started a business uh and the mission is
to just accelerate economic growth
globally uh and we were profitable
almost immediately out of the gate and
for 18 months we kind of just kept our
head down and we worked and we only
really took the money because we wanted
the right investors around the table we
didn't need the money we're still
profitable today um but it was a idea of
how do we get people who have tons more
experience and so
when you look through the entire cap
table what you find is these are
investors who are highly sophisticated
they've got tons of experience they've
built large companies before they've
invested in plenty of others that have
scaled aggressively uh and many of them
are very big proponents of the bitcoin
and crypto industry you mentioned uh
peter thiel you know he obviously spoke
at the bitcoin conference uh he's been a
bitcoin investor for a long time there's
folks like former allergan ceo brent
saunders and then there's folks that are
you know large family offices fit down
capital or you look at somebody like xyz
fund you know top 10
on the forbes midas list for seed
investors like these are real investors
who understand uh infrastructure is a
key piece to investing in a new sector
uh and while most companies focus on
building software infrastructure like
exchanges wallets data providers uh
people is a very key piece to it we
think that we can build out a niche
there and really scale i know you tend
to take the positive view on things but
there's a lot of talk out there about
projects that just might not make it
through this crypto winter what types of
projects are you most concerned about
are there tokens that are worth shying
away from
uh yeah pretty much all of them uh for
the most part um i think that even if
you talk to people who are big
proponents of the industry they'd say
the same thing uh anytime that you get
innovation uh happening it requires
experimentation first and so what you're
seeing is a ton of experimentation a lot
of bad ideas a lot of bad execution but
also a lot of bad market timing you know
if you go back to the late 90s and you
look at most of those ideas
they were the right ideas they just
didn't end up actually working uh in
that current iteration it took about 10
years or so before consumer behaviors
change before more people had internet
that wasn't dial-up mobile phones were
in their hands their kind of familiarity
uh their willingness to put their credit
card online all these different things
had to change and so i think some of
that is what we're seeing right now but
one thing is very clear there's over 150
million people around the world that uh
hold bitcoin and i think that bitcoin is
crossed over from something that people
look as an experiment or could possibly
be valuable and i think now what you're
seeing especially given the backdrop of
the undisciplined monetary and fiscal
policy is that bitcoin has now broken
out it's separated itself it is
different than most of the
experimentation of other things uh and
there's a lot of folks on wall street
and in silicon valley and then across
the world that say bitcoin is here today
and i tend to agree with